- I'm here with Louanna
who is a mom of three.
We've been talking about
her female support group,
we're talking about
divorce, divorce with kids,
and I actually was able to
bring in two fantastic women
to add to her support group.
Please meet money
expert, Carmen Rita Wong,
and relationship therapist,
Dr. Argie Allen Wilson.
(audience applauding)
Hi, guys.
- Hi. Hi, Drew.
- Hi.
- Hello.
- Carmen, in this support
group that we're building
in addition to Louanna's already existing
support group of female friends,
you are also a divorced single mother?
- Yes, ma'am, I am.
- Can I ask your advice?
In your specialty of finance,
do you have any advice for Louanna
while she is navigating this divorce?
- One of the most
important things you can do
when you go to the table to
finalize things financially
is keeping those kids in mind.
One of the best pieces
of advice that I got
when I was going through my divorce
was my attorney saying to me,
"You have more power than you know."
And that's at the financial table.
If you keep those kids in mind,
if they're your North Star,
then you can get some stability
and security in your life.
Whether it's their
education, health insurance,
whatever it is, always have them in mind
so you're coming at the
table with great energy,
positive energy, love for them,
but you're a little bit of a mama bear,
you know what I mean?
- Dr. Argie, is there any way
to emotionally prepare yourself
for signing divorce papers?
And this question comes with,
"God, I wish I had been able
to ask you that myself."
- (laughs) Well, thank
you for having me, Drew.
And Louanna, I have to say
that you are such an amazing inspiration.
It's true that divorce
is kinda like a death.
Think of divorce like a death,
but the truth is that it's the death
of the lifelong relationship
that we dreamed of.
So focus on radical self-care and action.
We can turn that pain into power, Louanna,
but in order to turn it into power,
we have to appreciate the process
so we can walk in our purpose.
That's the goal.
- Can I ask you a question, Louanna?
Do you have any ability to
have someone watch your kids
for the day that you
sign your divorce papers?
'Cause, looking back, I wish
I had done that for myself.
Faking it for them was
hell. I'm not gonna lie.
And if I had just had a window of a day
to process and be around friends
and just not have to put on that front...
It was very difficult.
- No, now that you mention it,
maybe I will get a babysitter.
Maybe I will go out to a lunch or a dinner
with my girlfriends or
make it just about me
and just do whatever I would love to do.
But that's an amazing idea.
I didn't even know that I...
I couldn't even think of that myself.
- We actually have a little
surprise for you, Louanna.
There were a few things that
some of your very best friends
wanted to tell you.
- Hi, Louanna.
I just wanted to let you
know how much I love you.
- I love you.
(inspiring music)
- You were there for me from everything
through the death of my mother,
Tim being deployed to Iraq.
- I admire your strength and tenacity \
over the last couple of years.
- I've seen you overcome
so many obstacles in life.
You've taught me that no
matter how hard life gets,
you can always bounce back and
better than you were before.
- You've risen above all the things
that you've been through.
- You really are one of the bravest
and most inspiring women
that I have ever met.
The last few years have not been easy.
There have been plenty of challenges.
The road is bumpy as hell.
- And know that I'm there for
you, no matter what, always.
- Don't ever change who you are.
And I'm always here for you.
- I am here to support you
in anything and everything.
I'm not going anywhere.
Bad girls for life.
I love you.
(music fades)
(audience applauding)
- Oh, my gosh. That was amazing.
Thank you so much.
I love it. Thanks so much.
- That group of girlfriends,
that is who you need to be with
on the day you sign those papers.
Get a babysitter.
If I could have a
get-in-the-DeLorean-and-do-it-differently,
I would not be in front
of my kids that day.
- Aw. No, thank you for
that recommendation.
I totally will plan it that way.
- I wanna thank Louanna
with all of my heart
for having what is a very
difficult discussion.
But trying to figure out how
to navigate it is everything.
And I really wanna thank
Dr. Argie and Carmen
for coming in and getting
into that support group
and sharing your wisdom and experience.
Thank you guys so much.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh ♪